one of the most anticipated cars this
year at the New York Auto Show is from a
company that otherwise has almost no
hype but that is the goal of a halo car
isn't it you've got to create excitement
one way or another nissan has done just
that with the world debut of its 2017
nissan gt-r AKA godzilla this is the
latest version to the two-door two by
two sports car that the company unveiled
in 2007 as a way to compete against the
likes at the audi r8 BMW m6 chevy
corvette and porsche 911 now while this
version isn't a totally redesigned
totally reconstructing next-generation
debut it is an update which is key
because well a total successor is
planned it is still a few years off
anyhow this latest version is pretty
legit it has been adjusted for improved
stability in aerodynamics but it has
maintained the same amazing hand-built
v6 engine that engine now has 565
horsepower which is 20 more than last
year the car has a new set of four
rounded taillights a totally redone rear
body a new hood and redesigned
headlights grille and air intakes that
give it that snarling grin inside
everything has been updated with napa
leather and then redesigned for maximum
driving performance from the looks of it
and what will likely be half the price
of better known supercars you're
probably going to love this newest
version more than ever the 2017 Nissan
GTR hits dealerships this summer
you